ein Anschlag auf eine Synagoge in
Hannover und da ist ein yom-kippur ist
am höchsten jüdischen Feiertag gegen 19
Uhr da ist plötzlich ein harter
Gegenstand mitten in die Synagoge
reingeworfen worden das Bleiglas Fenster
kaputt völlig zerstört Scherben in der
Synagoge in Hannover am Feiertag ja
völlig unklar noch wer der oder die
Täter sind die Ermittlung das sind sie
hier auch die laufen bei uns im Studio
bildchef Reporterin Antonia Jamin
Antonia grüße Dich Mensch Jom Kippur das
ist für alle Juden und Jüdin auch für
dich und deine Familie der höchste
Feiertag da kommt man zur Ruhe aber
diese Ruhe findet ihr finden alle Juden
in Deutschland seit Jahren eigentlich
nicht mehr zu jung also wirklich bis vor
ein paar Jahren war für mich und vor
ihnen auf der ganzen Welt Jom Kippur
wirklich ein Tag von Versöhnung ein Tag
der Ruhe man fastet an dem Tag man langt
das Handy nicht an man benutzt keinen
Strom man geht in sich herein man man
entschuldigt bei Menschen und das war
wirklich so ein Tag in dem fast nichts
auch passiert Israel ist dann auch
komplett leer also nichts passiert da
wirklich aber seit drei Jahren seit dem
Anschlag hier in Halle an Jom Kippur ist
dieser Tag einfach kein sicherer Tag
mehr das müssen wir noch mal sagen also
der Anschlag von Hannover jetzt eben in
den vergangenen Stunden zu Jom Kippur in
diesem Jahr und genau vor drei Jahren
passierte diese schreckliche Tat eben in
Halle genau und und seitdem ist es Jom
Kippur einfach kein sicherer Tag mehr
vor Juden in Deutschland Leute haben
Angst zu der Synagoge zu gehen sogar ich
ich bin jetzt nicht religiös ich bin
zirkulär aber auch säkuläre Juden gehen
manchmal zu der Synagoge speziell halt
Anion kippure wirklich der heiligste Tag
des Judentums ist ich dachte soll ich
jetzt mit meinen zweijährige Tochter zu
der Synagoge gehen wir leben in
Deutschland ich will trotzdem dass sie
ein jüdisches Leben hat
und ich habe und dann habe ich gesagt
nein also Berlin ist vielleicht sicherer
als andere Gemeinden in Deutschland und
trotzdem dachte ich mir zu diesem
Anschlussgebiet vielleicht heißt es auf
Hebräisch das mache ich nicht ich habe
einfach Angst dass das irgendwas
passieren kann und genau das passiert
dann in Hannover
dieser Stein oder dieses schwere was
auch immer da geschmissen worden ist das
ist sechs Meter hoch geschmissen worden
da sitzen auch die Frauen also da gibt's
ja die Frauen sitzen oben die Männer
sitzen unten wenn man so ein Stein oder
ein also das muss auch ein sehr großer
Stein gewesen sein weil man muss sich
vorstellen das sind ja keine normale
Fenstergläser die sind schon sehr dick
also man hat diesen Stein wahrscheinlich
auch mit voller Wucht dahin geschmissen
und ich frage wo waren wo war die
Sicherheit wo war die wo war die Polizei
von Hannover und drei Jahre Pfanne genau
an Jom Kippur wie kann das wie darf das
sowas überhaupt noch passieren so
traurig auch dass du schilderst dass du
Angst hast mit deinem Kind in die
Synagoge zu gehen am wichtigsten
Feiertag am Versöhnungstag wo es auch
für dich sicher persönlich sehr wichtig
ist deiner Tochter das alles zu zeigen
was sagt das darüber aus in was für
einer Gesellschaft wir leben was sagt
das darüber aus dass du als Jüdin sagst
oh es gibt besondere Tage da mache ich
bestimmte Dinge die mir wichtig sind
lieber nicht
also man sagt ja immer oder die
Politiker in Deutschland sagen ja immer
Antisemitismus hat keinen Platz in
Deutschland und immer wenn sowas
passiert sagen die Politiker wir schämen
uns davor aber irgendwie
passiert trotzdem nichts ich meine es
wenn es in jedem anderen Tag passiert
hätte wäre es immer noch schlimm aber
das das ist Anion kippure passiert genau
drei Jahre nach diesem Anschlag in Halle
man kann sich hier vorher schon denken
dass das dieser Tag so was von wichtig
ist dass das Leute auf die Idee kommen
würden sowas Anzug sowas zu machen also
und ich weiß auch dass vor diese
Synagoge in Hannover ein Polizeiwagen
eigentlich stehen soll wo waren die
Polizisten also weil weil dieser Täter
oder die Täter die das gemacht haben die
mussten sehr nah an die Synagoge kommen
um so einen schweren Stein sechs Meter
hoch zu schmeißen wie glücklicher wenn
irgendwann keine Polizeiautos mehr
stehen müssten vor Synagogen in
Deutschland danke dir bildreporterin
Antonia Jamin nach diesem Anschlag auf
eine Synagoge in Hannover drei Jahre
nachdem ein Neonazi eine Attacke in
Halle
[Musik]